après avoir passé le pic épidémique
l'espagne poursuit son déconfinement
depuis hier et barcelone et peuvent de
nouveau se balader sur les plages en
fait le point sur la situation avec un
canton au caire sous un grand soleil
ces barcelonais retrouve les plages de
la mer méditerranée
après plus de deux mois d'interdiction
si des sportives y avait un accès
restreint de 6h à 10h du matin depuis
une dizaine de jours ces plages sont
désormais ouvertes toute la journée
cependant la baignade reste proscrite
tout comme le bronzage et les sports
collectifs et la promenade doit se faire
obligatoirement en portant un masque des
restrictions loin d'être respectée ce
mercredi par des riverains qui ont des
difficultés à s'adapter à la situation
s'étouffant mais nécessaire de porter ce
masque il faut l'utiliser mais il arrive
un moment où vous été soufflé en fait
nous ne savions pas nous sommes venus
courir nous avions très chaud et nous
nous sommes baignés il y avait beaucoup
de monde sur la plage alors on s'est dit
pourquoi pas les autorités espagnoles
ont décrété que le port du masque sera
obligatoire dans tous les lieux publics
y compris dans la rue si une
distanciation de deux mètres est
impossible à respecter cette mesure
s'applique à toutes les personnes de 6
ans et plus le gouvernement souhaite
également prolongé l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
la prolongation de l'état d'urgence que
nous souhaitons et de 15 jours car le
développement de la pandémie nous oblige
à être prudents
l'état d'urgence doit rester en vigueur
tant qu'il est nécessaire de restreindre
partiellement certains droits au nom de
la santé publique et pas un jour de plus
je veux demander pardon à nos
concitoyens pour les erreurs commises
dans l'urgence en raison de la pénurie
de ressources du caractère exceptionnel
de cette crise et de son ampleur comme
de l'absence de précédent
dès ce moment là et si pour 70% du pays
la vie a repris très prudemment son
cours dans les régions de madrid
barcelone et de castille leon des
limitations plus strictes demeure hier
pedro sanchez a donc présenté ses
excuses aux espagnols pour je cite les
erreurs commises dans l'urgence ces
déclarations font suite aux nombreuses
manifestations
les stations qui ont eu lieu dans le
pays lundi pour demander sa démission
je suis là pour exiger que monsieur
sanchez parc par skréla ruines de ce
pays
j'ai failli lui demander poliment de
partir qu'ils nous laissent qu'il
organise des élections et qu'ils
laissent les espagnols s'exprimer
cet homme est au pouvoir de façon
injustifiée qu'il parte
l'espagne compte plus de 27000 800 décès
depuis qu'a commencé la pandémie ce
mercredi le nombre de décès quotidiens
liés aux kovy 19 est resté en dessous
des 100 morts pour le quatrième jour
consécutif